As usual, we will start
by reading in our data
and looking at it
in the R console.
So we can create a data
frame called polling
using the read.csv function
for our PollingData.csv file.
And we can take a look at its
structure with the str command.
And what we can see
is that as expected,
we have a state and a year
variable for each observation,
as well as some polling
data and the outcome
variable, Republican.
So something we notice
right off the bat
is that even though there are
50 states and three election
years, so we would
expect 150 observations,
we actually only have 145
observations in the data frame.
So using the table
function, we can
look at the breakdown of the
polling data frame's Year
variable.
And what we see is that while
in the 2004 and 2008 elections,
all 50 states have data
reported, in 2012, only 45
of the 50 states have data.
And actually, what
happened here is
that pollsters were so sure
about the five missing states
that they didn't perform any
polls in the months leading up
to the 2012 election.
So since these states are
particularly easy to predict,
we feel pretty comfortable
moving forward, making
predictions just for
the 45 remaining states.
So the second thing
that we notice
is that there are
these NA values, which
signify missing data.
So to get a handle on just
how many values are missing,
we can use our summary function
on the polling data frame.
And what we see is that
while for the majority
of our variables, there's
actually no missing data,
we see that for the
Rasmussen polling data
and also for the
SurveyUSA polling data,
there are a decent
number of missing values.
So let's take a
look at just how we
can handle this missing data.
There are a number
of simple approaches
to dealing with missing data.
One would be to
delete observations
that are missing at
least one variable value.
Unfortunately, in
this case, that
would result in throwing
away more than 50%
of the observations.
And further, we want to be
able to make predictions
for all states, not
just for the ones that
report all of their
variable values.
Another observation would be
to remove the variables that
have missing values, in
this case, the Rasmussen
and SurveyUSA variables.
However, we expect
Rasmussen and SurveyUSA
to be qualitatively different
from aggregate variables,
such as DiffCount
and PropR, so we
want to retain them
in our data set.
A third approach would be
to fill the missing data
points with average values.
So for Rasmussen and SurveyUSA,
the average value for a poll
would be very close to
zero across all the times
with it reported,
which is roughly a tie
between the Democrat and
Republican candidate.
However, if PropR is very
close to one or zero,
we would expect the
Rasmussen or SurveyUSA
values that are
currently missing
to be positive or
negative, respectively.
This leads to a more
complicated approach
called multiple imputation in
which we fill in the missing
values based on the non-missing
values for an observation.
So for instance, if the
Rasmussen variable is reported
and is very negative, then
the missing SurveyUSA value
would likely be filled in
as a negative value as well.
Just like in the
sample.split function,
multiple runs of
multiple imputation
will in general result in
different missing values being
filled in based on the
random seed that is set.
Although multiple
imputation is in general
a mathematically
sophisticated approach,
we can use it rather easily
through pre-existing R
libraries.
We will use the
Multiple Imputation
by Chained Equations,
or mice package.
So just like we did in
lecture with the ROCR package,
we're going to
install and then load
a new package, the mice package.
So we run
install.packages, and we
pass it mice, which is
the name of the package we
want to install.
So you have to select a mirror
near you for the installation,
and hopefully everything
will go smoothly
and you'll get the
package mice installed.
So after it's
installed, we still
need to load it so that
we can actually use it,
so we do that with
the library command.
If you have to use it in the
future, all you'll have to do
is run library instead of
installing and then running
library.
So for our multiple
imputation to be useful,
we have to be able to find
out the values of our missing
variables without using
the outcome of Republican.
So, what we're
going to do here is
we're going to limit
our data frame to just
the four polling
related variables
before we actually perform
multiple imputation.
So we're going to create a
new data frame called simple,
and that's just going to be
our original polling data
frame limited to Rasmussen,
SurveyUSA, PropR,
and DiffCount.
We can take a look
at the simple data
frame using the summary command.
What we can see
is that we haven't
done anything fancy yet.
We still have our
missing values.
All that's changed
is now we have
a smaller number of
variables in total.
So again, multiple imputation,
if you ran it twice,
you would get different
values that were filled in.
So, to make sure that
everybody following along
gets the same results
from imputation,
we're going to set the
random seed to a value.
It doesn't really
matter what value
we pick, so we'll just pick
my favorite number, 144.
And now we're ready
to do imputation,
which is just one line.
So we're going to create a
new data frame called imputed,
and we're going to use
the function complete,
called on the function
mice, called on simple.
So the output here shows us
that five rounds of imputation
have been run, and now
all of the variables
have been filled in.
So there's no more
missing values,
and we can see that using the
summary function on imputed.
So Rasmussen and SurveyUSA
both have no more
of those NA or missing values.
So the last step in
this imputation process
is to actually copy the
Rasmussen and SurveyUSA
variables back into our original
polling data frame, which
has all the variables
for the problem.
And we can do that with
two simple assignments.
So we'll just copy over to
polling Rasmussen, the value
from the imputed data
frame, and then we'll
do the same for the
SurveyUSA variable.
And we'll use one final
check using summary
on the final polling data frame.
And as we can see,
Rasmussen and SurveyUSA
are no longer missing values.